-Hey!
Thanks so much for doing this.
It is great to see you.
-Great to see you.
-I want to talk to you about
a couple cool things
that you're doing.
One you did during quarantine.
You taught a Broadway
Zoom class.
-Yeah.
-What was that like?
And how did you get involved?
And had you ever taught
a class before?
-Well, first of all, I'd never
taught a class before,
and I was -- I think I was
way more terrified
than any of the students,
way more nervous.
But my friend actually created
this platform.
It's amazing.
It's called "Broadway Weekend."
And it's where Broadway
and West End professionals
teach theater classes
whenever their schools
are online.
And it's created this like
global community.
And it's great because,
you know, when these performers
can't perform
'cause of lockdown
they're getting to share
their skills
and people at home
can be creative
and learn and try
and have some fun.
-That's a great idea.
-I really recommend everyone
to check it out.
-Once you did it,
did you feel better at it,
once you started doing it?
-I mean, I was teaching
audition technique,
which is completely insane
because I am
terrible at auditions.
-I know that you audition
for "Mamma Mia" was a --
It ended up being a big weekend
for you.
'Cause -- Was it Glastonbury?
-Yeah.
God. I mean, it was insane.
I knew I had to sing
in this audition.
I was desperate for this part.
But I was meant to be scheduled
at the end of Glastonbury
Music Festival
and I knew for sure that
after screaming in a field
for five days, there was no way
I'd be able to sing.
-Oh, my gosh.
-So I did it on the way.
I had the car packed with the
stuff and the whirlies
and the outfits,
and then I went in, I sang,
went to Glastonbury
and my phone ran out
of battery,
and I think I found out --
I think they tried to
call me and tell me
I got the part,
and it wasn't until I was
in the car on the way home
I plugged in my phone
and I listened --
and my agent calls me
and I'm like,
[ Hoarse voice ]
"Hello?"
[ Laughter ]
"You got the job."
I'm like, "Please say
it doesn't start soon."
[ Laughter ]
-You're the lead
in "Mamma Mia 2."
You're like, [ Hoarse voice ]
"Oh, this is fantastic.
Oh, God."
-"Great news."
[ Laughter ]
"Thank you."
-Speaking of "Mamma Mia,"
this summer the producers
actually said that it was
meant to be a trilogy.
So there may be a "Mamma Mia 3"
in the works.
Would you be interested
if that --
-Yeah.
I'd want to do like
"4," "5," "6," "7,"
"8," "9," "10."
I'm down. I'm like, signed,
sealed, delivered on those.
-Yeah. Hey, I want to talk
about "Rebecca,"
your new movie which is based on
the famous book.
It's part love story, it's
part thriller, part mystery.
Can you set up what it's about?
-It's based on the book
by Daphne du Maurier.
It's the most wonderful,
wonderful book.
And it starts as this
sweeping romance
and then you follow this
newlywed, who I play.
She follows her husband to
this -- back to England
to this huge, imposing estate
called Mandley,
which is almost a character
in itself,
and this story sort of
flip reverses
into a gothic horror
ghost story
and it becomes just terrifying.
It's got a great cast.
Kristen Scott Thomas plays
Mrs. Danvers and she's just --
-Come on.
-Oh, just chilling
and wonderful in every way.
-I love that you got her --
I mean, that someone
got her to do this.
'Cause I thought she was only
going to do theater.
-She's honestly --
I just adore her.
-Yeah.
-And she's so --
She flips the part as well.
It kind of becomes --
because Hitchcock made this film
too very famously,
and she flips this part
from the villain to almost
the moral compass from the film.
-She's brilliant.
And Ben Wheatley directed it,
and he also --
he's so good at delving into the
darkness of our human psyche.
And so it's a psychological
thriller, really.
-Yeah. Yeah, have you ever had
any experiences with
ghosts yourself?
-You know what?
I just figured something out
and I'm a bit traumatized by it,
which is that my whole life
I've had these
reoccurring nightmares
where a dark figure
walks towards me
and like leans over me.
And I wake up screaming.
And it goes into
my consciousness,
and whoever I've been with
will be like,
"It's okay, Lily.
It's okay, Lily."
I was in a dorm
for nearly ten years
with one girl
when I was at school,
and she'd comfort me
once a week.
Always once a week,
I'd wake up screaming.
And I had only just realized
this, but her name is Rebecca.
-No. You're kidding.
-No, I'm not kidding.
So I think she's been screwing
with me my entire life.
-Oh, my gosh.
Dude, now the dreams are going
to get crazier and crazier.
No, they won't.
I'm going to put it out there
in the world right now.
They're gone.
Yeah. I will --
-Okay, good.
-Yeah, I'll talk to somebody.
I'll make sure it's all good.
-Can you please?
-I do want to show everyone
a clip, though.
Here are Lily James and
Armie Hammer in "Rebecca."
Take a look.
-Bonjour.
-Mademoiselle.
Ah. Madam Van Hopper's
usual table.
-Oh, yes, thank you, merci.
Oh, no.
Wait. Sorry.
She was wondering
if a Mr. De Winter
could sit with her.
-Monsieur Maxim De Winter?
-Oui.
-It is the choice
of Mr. De Winter
where he wishes to be seated.
-Oh, yes.
Of course.
Merci.
So sorry.
Is that not good enough?
Here, I've got more.
[ Coins dropping ]
God, I'm so sorry, monsieur.
Just one moment.
-Don't do it.
I've heard he's a terrible bore.
-Excuse me?
-This De Winter chap.
-Thank you.
-Monsieur De Winter,
please, this way.
-Lily James.
"Rebecca" is streaming
on Netflix and in select
theaters right now.